[Music]
I just had a big Darrin it's 1:00 in the
morning enjoy having sex with me
absolutely yes as much as you you stay
yes Wow
I've seen the film before so I'm not on
the edge of my seat but it's still my
favorite film of all time you don't have
kids we have actually been trying for
kids for a while now with your
complications conceiving is very
unlikely what do we do now
a small piece of us dies and we just
carry on with whatever's left all right
well as long as you've got a plan
I think already super adopting God be
careful with adoption Mel from the club
got a rescue dog shat everywhere I don't
know what to do with that information
need to convince people that were great
and they're gonna judge us
[Music]
we should make a list of you the floors
that we want to iron out you drink too
much you should stop smoking you need to
get stronger emotion that you need to
work on your anger I think we're gonna
be amazing Pervin it is not a test I am
on your side this is about preparing you
for panel so how often would you say you
have sex it's a scary business
my kids are vampires that suck every
ounce of energy about men to learn
nothing but an empty Karthus barber
tonight you all right yeah
[Music]
change a bit scary you can't get too
attached to what you think your life's
gonna be love you
how do people even like this I love
L'Amour like that
[Music]
oh for God's sake you know how to do it
you are they are tiny little miracles
lemon tea Twitter followers can wait
talk to your children they're not my
children in the place we can't get a
criminal record they won't give us a kid
sorry mate we're not bad people it's
just it's just very
[Music]
you
you